Hey, Vsauce. Michael here. And that's the
view from outside my apartment,
which I won't be going out in because a
hurricane is coming.
But don't worry, there are plenty of
things to do online now guys.
To learn about yourself, MisterStopert
suggests what happened
my birth year. It unravels slowly and
gives some fun
perspective.
But Sporcle is the Olympics of
geekiness. Some of its games are easy, like Guess the Font and some are amazingly difficult.
For the past few weeks I've been memorizing
national flags and on Sporcle
you have to know the flag
and spell the country right. Even more
geographic is this US drag-and-drop.
Grab a state and place it in its correct
location. The game averages how many
miles
you're off.
If you like being tested and you like Tetris,
you can play Statetris. They've got all
kinds of maps, where the countries fall like
Tetris pieces
you have to manipulate and properly place.
If you're already a geo wizz, try
Which Is It's Dog Breed Trivia game.
But why look at shapes,
when you could just type? Z-Type is an awesome
game where you have to type the enemy's
word. Each correct letter is a shot.
Of course,
it's more fun to prove you're a human.
Captcha invaders sends ships to attack
your city
and your only defense is filling out the captions.
If you'd rather avoid facts and have
pretty colors, Bioniccommando1000
sent me
RetroShoot. You steer with the mouse,
never stop firing
and it feels so good when you let off a bomb.
He also recommended Monito. Your cursor
is attached to a ball with a springy
string,
so watch that its momentum doesn't throw
it into danger.
But if you'd rather cut stuff, play Splitter,
where clever slicing
gets you results.
Tomdemey sent me
Gravity Guy. Your character constantly
runs and it's up to you
to reverse and re-reverse gravity at just
the right time to keep his path smooth.
For more constant change, MissBabygirl3601
sent over Four Second Frenzy,
a barrage of games where you only have four
seconds to complete
each one using only the arrow keys and
the spacebar. When you're done playing
games, here are some things you can do on
YouTube now guys.
Yesterday Jake showed me these awesome
videos of the world
where a guys integrates his hands like
he's playing with people and cars
as if they're his toys. Also interesting
is this video about a structure
built by artist Wim Delvoye.
It's a machine containing
enzymes, bacteria, grinders, pumps.
You put real food
in one end and out the other -
I'm not kidding - comes actual,
synthetically made, poop.
Have a good weekend.
And as always,
thanks for watching.